here is a short venture into the failed
ideas that are floating around to fight
coronavirus Louisiana is a state that is
really suffering with coronavirus
Louisiana has the fourth most cases per
capita Louisiana has the seventh most
deaths per capita but most importantly
the disease is quickly returning to
Louisiana where from early June through
yesterday cases have gone higher and
higher Louisiana has more people
actively infected today than at any
previous point during the pandemic so
what does Louisiana Governor John bel
Edwards do well he obviously calls for
three days of prayer and fasting
now bel Edwards is a Democrat by the way
he says pastors reached out to him and
said you know you should maybe support
fasting and prayer to deal with the
virus so he's going to be calling for it
statewide take a look at this I do want
to let you all know that every couple of
three weeks I have a the opportunity to
have a conference call with hundreds of
pastors across the state of Louisiana
and last week we had such a call and
received a request and I'm happy to
honor today and and it's I know it's a
little bit unusual but but I think it's
it's something that's it's important at
least for me and those people on the
call and many other Louisianans so I'm
going to call for three days of fasting
in prayer for our state for July 20th
through the 22nd that's the the 20th to
21st to 22nd this will be the spiritual
diet and exercise that I as a Catholic
Christian believes very important anyway
so we'll be doing lunch fasting for
those three days and certainly praying
as well praying for the people of
Louisiana praying for those who were
sick praying for those who care for
those who were sick and certainly
praying for the families of those who
have passed on you know he he is right
when he says it's unusual that started
yesterday
by the way July 20th the fasting and
prayer supposed to be yesterday today
and tomorrow now as he mat Mehta said
Hemant he Mont Mehta said in a blog post
what bel edwards does in his spare time
is really his business but what pastors
want him to do should be irrelevant from
the standpoint of public announcements
as the secular governor of the state of
Louisiana now I don't mean personally a
religious I mean that the governorship
itself should be secular separated from
religion there's no reason to tell
people of the state to do a religious
ritual to fight a virus we know what he
should be calling for we know what needs
to be done everybody should be wearing a
mask
which he did say in his defense no large
group gatherings mostly stay home
certainly no indoor dining we know what
to do and the mask part he did say but
he's calling for prayer and fasting and
you know some people are defending this
by saying he said this is it
nondenominational right skip lunch and
and pray regardless of your denomination
what about people who aren't religious
this is still a government actor who is
supposed to be separate from the church
establishing a religious act
I mean prayer is a religious act over
non-religion and it's another example of
of this you know we've tried nothing and
we're out of ideas I mean he's already
going to pray or and fasting and it's a
Democratic governor not a Republican
this is not about political party for me
mostly this type of stuff is in the
Republican Party but here's an example
of it from the Democratic side this is
certainly a conservative Democrat don't
be confused but still this is a Democrat
and it reminds me of the situation in
Mississippi actually we've talked about
Mississippi Mississippi is tragically
suffering and has been for decades in
the United States and yet they're
talking and doing nonsense in
Mississippi it was how can we block
black voters from from voting or how can
we make sure that more real
Mississippians register because the
blacks are really registering to vote
meanwhile Mississippi is almost dead
last
or dead last in health care
education etc etc Louisiana is one of
the most ravaged states by most
indicators Louisiana's 45th and
healthcare 48th and education 49th in
economic growth
48th and infrastructure 50th in dealing
with climate change it's a disaster in
Louisiana and then you look over and how
are they dealing with coronavirus well
the governor suggests skipping lunch and
praying
hmm now someone wrote to me something
that that is interesting which is could
this be indirectly brilliant in other
words bel edwards could be appealing to
religiosity by saying fast during lunch
lunch is when a lot of folks go out
especially if they're working maybe by
saying skip lunch
he's keeping people out of restaurants
and it's actually going to stop the
spread I don't know it's an interesting
question it's certainly the most
charitable interpretation of fast and
pray to stop the virus but that's not
really what what this is about this is
not about reverse engineering some way
in which a call for fasting and prayer
might connect to better health outcomes
with coronavirus this is a governor a
public elected official he has no place
suggesting religious prayer and fasting
on the say-so of Christian pastors as a
solution for a public health crisis and
again look at how poorly things are
going in Louisiana we have to ask
whether these things are connected we're
gonna have more about this on the David
Pakman show
Instagram page make sure you are
following us there at david pakman show
and while you're on your Instagram app
follow me at David Pakman we'll take a
quick break we do have tragic news to
discuss coming up after the interview
and I hope you'll be with me at the end
of the show if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blinka stinketh lets you consume an
entire
book on your way home from work they
take thousands of popular nonfiction
books condense each one into text or
audio that you can get through in just
15 minutes and you get all of the
important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video